disney has announced that it will not be
sending executives or stars to las vegas
next month
for cinemacons citing an increase in
covet cases here and there's already
some concern about major conventions
possibly canceling trips here all
together orco man and joining us live
from the convention
center with more on this orco
well brian as of right now no major
conventions or trade shows have canceled
their trips to las vegas
but local leaders and businesses are
worried that could happen
if our coven numbers do not get better
it's still on as of now frank
friedlander is holding on to hope the
hospitality trade show where he's
supposed to be an exhibitor is still
scheduled for august on the las vegas
strip
and if it didn't happen he'd be worried
would it hurt us
definitely friedlander owns tough skin
surface protection a company that seals
marble to prevent etching or stains
he says without conventions it's hard to
get new customers to miss it for two
years in a row
because of covid would be a big
a big damper on our business the concern
over potential convention cancellations
is a result of rising covet cases in
southern nevada clark county
commissioners brought up the issue at
their meeting last week
we are getting lots of calls around the
country
to you know know if
trade conventions are going to be safe
to come here it would be detrimental to
us cindy kester does hoa management and
is preparing for a national conference
coming to las vegas next month
as of now the event is still happening
but major components will be missing
there is a concern with our growth of
covid
that we've increased a little bit and
we've had a few speakers cancel out at
the last minute
knowing things could change at any
minute friedlander is preparing for the
worst
i'm going to make the best of the
situation regardless of what it is
again there have not been any official
announcements of conventions canceling
yet
the businesses we spoke to say in order
to avoid that we all have to do our part
to stop the spread of kovid 19.
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now